hey guys I'm Ryan right I'm Katie Dubois
I'm Jerry today we're gonna do a special
review of Ironman oh special spoiler
talk here when we started the channel
the first Marvel movie we were able to
do was Iron Man 3 so here we are today
to talk about Iron Man let's do this
ladies and gentlemen Ironman Ironman
I remember watching this we fought
together I remember watching this movie
this was a huge [ __ ] deal because
this was like Marvel Studios his first
real film not like oh this is really
Fox's movie you know what I mean like
this is Marvel's movie it was a big deal
because there was Robert Downey jr. and
at the time that was like really
pressuring for Robert Downey I heard
that he only got paid like half a
million dollars for it yes this movie
was a pretty sizeable gamble because to
like Iron Man is more a comic book II
it's not like one of those household
names like spider-man or Batman so it's
like alright we're gonna take a Robert
Downey jr. who hasn't had a career in a
long time and we're gonna take this
lesser-known kind of superhero that we
really only know like the nerd Aneesh
knows about and we're gonna make a
big-budget movie out of it and sort of
try and spark our franchise and it
worked really well right from the
beginning I love it because you
immediately get new Tommy star kids when
they're in the Humvee and the soldiers
are like bonding with Tony and he's
drinking taking photos of them you
immediately get a strong sense of who
Tony Stark is what I loved about the
first Ironman looking over it again is
that the magic of it is really all the
details of the film you know the
explosion goes off cuz it was a cool
opening I liked what director Jon
Favreau did with it because it
established a really good tone of humor
that will feature some intense drama
yeah because then it cuts back to like
was like three days earlier or three
weeks earlier or something like that you
know I asked you something about Jeff
Bridges Obadiah Stane I immediately
thought he was a bad guy and there's
something about that look when people
have like a shaved head or like a super
tight buzz cut with a big beard that's
like I don't quite trust this guy
something about Jeff Bridges performance
- made me kind of not trust him I wasn't
worried about it though it's not like
they gave you that little nugget
and then you were like oh crap now I
know the end yeah the good guys we got
the bad guys let's keep going let's see
whether what happens there's there's
enough other stuff to discover and stuff
because it is like an origin story to
that like you know you don't get hung up
on that because he is a pretty
suspicious cat you know and he's in that
position in these kinds of stories to be
the unseen there should have been my
company like that kind of position
but I do like the scenes with him and
Tony there is a level of history and
understanding even when he's being
deceitful you can still tell how Tony is
not able to pick up on it yeah cuz he's
it's he's practically a family member
yeah it must been pretty traumatic for
Tony actually him but it didn't really
seem to bother him the rest of the
movies well you know I'm sure is in that
tightly wound rubberband ball of traumas
that slowly starts to battle over the
course of the series you know who I
really like rody Tarantino today you
know so fun I next time
I personally between Don Cheadle on him
I still personally prefer Terrence
Howard I've seen to da yayo performances
of rody
and I've seen the dynamics between Tony
Stark and rody and Iron Man 1 we're so
[ __ ] good every moment of them felt
like these guys have been best friends
for a long time you know I love the
relationship dynamic of Tony's like this
annoying douchebag to him but he loves
him at the same time does that grit
that's I mean there's details in it
there's a great moment where they're on
the plane
Tony's like just have a dream just have
a drink and he's like no you see how
like serious he is right and then they
get drunk and like there's Nazca yeah
and he's like pouring out his heart to
Tony I can imagine them at college I can
imagine them like messing with girls in
middle school yeah that's a long history
a long history double penetrating tricks
probably not
I could see Tony doing that half and
Rody's huge black [ __ ] balls [ __ ]
warmish is when Tony gets captured by
the terrorists you know he his
assignment assistant
yinsen who I really liked in this movie
you know I thought I wish more people
walked away talking about yinsen
tshirt without yen send he really
wouldn't have become Iron Man I mean not
just physically but emotionally as well
like he was able to build the suit yes
because of the instance help but at the
same time like you see
Tony's understanding of the world better
through yen sense eyes as well whenever
he's bonding with him and that's the
first time that he took on any direct
responsibility for someone else's life
yes to that he's just shooting missiles
off into God knows where and he feeling
like he's protecting America but in that
moment he actually sees someone go down
because of the consequences of his
actions
oh yeah see he sees like the horrible
byproducts of his work and then it
becomes more than just industry yeah I
really like the evolution of Tony's
characters about this whole thing you
know because when he comes back to
America he's just a changed man
and I love him but he's like I just want
to get a burger when he's like obsessed
for getting a burger that he shows up a
burger came great profit placement by
the way in that moment you know they go
to the he goes to the press conference
he asked everyone to just sit down with
him you see how like this guy yes he's
traumatized but he's also change in a
better way
well he's still Tony Stark he's just
Tony Stark with a better sense for
what's going on in the world yeah and
and more of a sense of duty now whereas
before he was just kind of soaking up
the status quo
I like the motivation he develops to
become Ironman because I see a lot of
comic-book stories that go oh a family
member dies and they're like oh justice
but he Tony saw that hey these
terrorists are like using my weapons
actually yeah and he's seen the
destruction and the turmoil that his
weapons are causing and he wants to make
its story about redemption making a
difference for yourself as well because
there is that powerful moment where he's
talking uh when it's Paltrow where he's
talking about like he feels like he has
to do this and she's like no you don't
have to you don't have to dumb [ __ ]
well most that thing I'm like I can't
trust the world to do it because even
the military later on like wants iron
man all that stuff it's like I can only
trust myself to be trustworthy with this
machinery
mm-hmm and to you know make a difference
in the world but Gwyneth Paltrow
some people really don't like her as
never but I like her a lot I like her I
can see why you wouldn't but III
I think she needs to be in many ways and
equal to him
she needs to be intelligent she needs to
have class she needs to compliment him
he's crazy and messy she's the one
keeping his appointment he balances him
out very well exactly and they have
great scenes together any moment they're
together his great chemistry like right
away that moment where he has the chest
plate and the energy things dying down
just to get in there there's some great
effects on that right that really looked
like she was reaching down into his
chest but he was he had a part hollowed
out no that's really good and his heart
next very nice any moment they have
together is great I need one more chance
to kick that other girl out in the
morning oh yeah it's a great script
because you get a good grasp of all
these characters just in their
interactions we could talk about like
all the action and stuff but everyone's
already talked about that before like
it's so good you know it's beautiful to
look at I mean all you gotta say is like
the actions cool and the effects are
good yeah okay in the finale though I
didn't really like what they did with
Obadiah how he just big chunky he gets
in the [ __ ] eye that junkie Iron Man
suit and then he's knows how to operate
it flawlessly yeah and he's like look
how evil I am Tony a little bit more of
an origin story for him in that way like
Tony had to learn how to be Iron Man he
could have learned how to be yeah a
little bit more yeah he could you know
study the schematics
yeah no but I was mainly just business
to he doesn't have the size I'll tell
you don't know man you don't know maybe
he's at home every night like drinking
wheatgrass and doing Krav Maga you know
he doesn't look like maybe he goes on
pornhub a lot really muscular forearms
when he watches pornhub he's like yeah
oh my god future born Minority Report
but in the ending I love the way this
film ends what an interesting
cliffhanger because it's so common for
the superhero to hide their identity
yeah
yeah we're not gonna do all that
secretive she didn't that way I mean
that character has always been like this
is me yeah it made sense for him to do
that but it was such a good cliffhanger
because he's like cool whoa he just
revealed his identity in the first movie
well I was cool especially like for
Marvel as an autonomous studio to come
in with a bang and just be like you know
what we're gonna do it this way and it's
kind of different and of course yeah
used to and he's an egomaniac there's
nothing that humble about him actually
yeah he wants to fix these problems but
he wants to fix them yeah it makes sense
to his character and it's kind of an odd
choice because it's just not when you
see a lot totally and of course the
post-credits thing oh yeah I remember
watching into theaters everyone lost
their [ __ ] when you Samuel Jackson's
like I'm pretty together the Avengers he
was rumored but it would confirmed it
yeah you know like it was a beautiful
way to do it years worth of Nick Fury
post-credits sting jokes were born that
yeah but it totally paid off too
yeah it totally paid off so yeah Iron
Man it's a great movie solid script
solid directing cuz Robert Downey jr.
went from five hundred thousand dollar
paycheck to ten million dollar paycheck
for Iron Man to which he deserved a lot
more money for a criminal now is like
the highest-paid actor in Hollywood
rating system time I should really start
preparing these ratings Iron Man is a
deliciously solid time Iron Man is let's
give a consensus system that quality of
like something on the long lines of like
excellent grip or awful 10-inch
anyway guys if you're new the channel
you can subscribe to the real rejects
Jerry has to play this on this channel
reasons to Jerry you can fact check that
movie reviews Katie has a channel to has
like sketches short films now she just
started doing comic book reviews so
check that out man she just reviewed
preacher rad preacher this she's gonna
do preacher to write electric Boogaloo
and one day I'll guess I'm
for HBO I know Nancy IMC Seth Rogen and
Evan Goldberg anyway guys yeah we're
tuning out now but you could also follow
us on Facebook Instagram and Twitter
because we want you guys to be involved
in our personal lives as much as
possible
yeah our personal lives personal I
talked about you're all invited to
Ryan's wedding I talked about the
deepest darkest secret and jiggly jelly
is gonna be your best man like anal even
dark oh thanks it doesn't sound like it
that's a secret it's not a secret the
secret is actually law of attraction